lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es a
través de un buen de ejemplos tratar de
familiarizarnos con el plano coordenada
xy en principio vamos a ver estos puntos
que ya están gráfica 2 y determinar
cuáles son sus coordenadas y después
vamos a ver estas coordenadas y ver
dónde se pintan en el plano así que
primero vamos a determinar cuáles son
las coordenadas de estos puntos digamos
tienes este punto a justo aquí así que
su coordenada x es si dejas caer digamos
hasta el eje x nos da que x es igual a 5
así que este tiene coordenadas 5,2 vamos
hacia el eje y nos dice que es 6
ahora tenemos aquí el punto b aquí cuál
es su coordenada x es menos 5 5 a la
izquierda del eje x
ok entonces su coordenada x es menos 5 y
su coordenada y justo nos vamos hacia la
derecha y vemos que golpea en el 5 así
que es igual a 5 déjenme cambiar colores
y ahora se ya creo que tienes idea de
qué es lo que estamos haciendo su
coordenada y por ejemplo vamos a empezar
ahora con esto es 3 y su coordenada x es
menos 2 siempre ponemos la coordenada x
primero esta es la convención que usamos
ahora desde el punto de coordenada x es
menos 2 y lo mismo su coordenada en ye
verdad ahora déjenme otro color ahora
vámonos con su coordenada y vamos con su
coordenada y bueno esto es menos 4
puedes verlo aquí justo a la izquierda
del punto y su coordenada x es 3
finalmente efe
efe tiene coordenada en x2 y coordenada
menos 6 en y espero que esto ya nos dé
mucha idea de cómo es que identificamos
las coordenadas en el plano ahora
tenemos las coordenadas y vamos a dar
los puntos primero tenemos este
ok este que estoy enmarcando entonces
este es un 42 x es igual a 4 y es igual
a 2
y es igual a 2 subimos así que es este
punto de aquí mismo vamos a hacer el
siguiente vamos a hacerlo en otro color
para que tengas oportunidad de verlo x
es igual a menos 3 ok y es igual a 5.5
entonces subimos hasta 5.5 perfecto así
que este punto de aquí que estamos
poniendo como b entre paréntesis es el
que nos dicen ahora se tiene coordenadas
4 menos 4 y entonces nos vamos 4 para
abajo y aquí está c
ahora 1 último lo voy a hacer en naranja
que tiene coordenada x menos dos nos
vamos a menos dos y menos tres en así
que aquí justamente está el punto de y
podrías pensarlo de varias formas si es
igual a menos tres y equis es igual a
menos dos podría decirte dos a la
izquierda y tres abajo o tres abajo y
dos a la izquierda aún así llegarías al
mismo punto espero que esto te haya dado
buen sentido de cómo hacer figuras con
coordenadas y demás pero bueno ahora
vamos a intentar un problema un poquito
más complicado dice el si los siguientes
tres puntos son tres vértices de un
cuadrado
abc de ponlos en una gráfica y determina
que coordina qué coordenadas tiene el
cuarto punto d
gráfica lo como un punto y etiqueta lo
entonces tenemos nuestro eje i
este es el eje y tenemos el eje el eje x
el eje horizontal y déjenme poner
algunas marcas digamos esto es x igual a
1234 y aquí está x igual a menos 1 - 2 -
3 y menos 4 ahora y es igual a 1 234 y
de igual a menos 1 - 2 - 3 y menos 4
podría escribirlo
aquí los cuatro digamos para tener más
referencias
aquí x igual a menos 4 y veremos vamos a
graficar estos puntos así que primero
tenemos el punto a que es igual a menos
4 menos 4 entonces nos vamos 4 a la
izquierda y 4 para abajo ok
este es nuestro punto a
menos cuatro menos cuatro y solo para
familiarizarnos un poquito con las
etiquetas la gente acostumbra a llamarle
a estas secciones el primer cuadrante
segundo cuadrante tercer cuadrante y
cuarto cuadrante cuadrante perdón y son
los números romanos para 1 2 3 y 4 así
que este punto queda en el tercer
cuadrante si vemos en estas cosas de acá
arriba estos puntos están en el cuarto
cuadrante tercero segundo primero y solo
como una cosa interesante algunas
personas dicen bueno si ambas
coordenadas son negativas entonces van a
estar en el tercer cuadrante si es
negativo pero x es positivo estás en el
cuarto cuadrante cuadrante perdón si
ambos son positivos estás en el primero
y sigue es positivo pero x es negativo
estamos en el segundo cuadrante ahora
bien ve tiene x positivo y de hecho es 3
y es negativo así que caemos de este
lado en el cuarto cuadrante y aquí está
b que tiene coordenadas 3 menos 4
así que ya podemos encontrar la base de
nuestro rectángulo verdad
notemos que tienen la misma coordenada y
así que están al mismo nivel debajo del
eje x cuál es el siguiente punto el
punto s que es el 33 ok
está en el primer cuadrante y ambos
tienen coordenadas positivas verdad
tanto xy notemos que está en la misma
línea vertical que ve eso quiere decir
que tiene el mismo mismo valor que x
está justo arriba de él ahora vamos a
poder encontrar el último punto verdad
porque el último punto el último vértice
debe estar en la misma línea vertical
que a lo cual significa que debe tener
su mismo valor x así que su valor x es
menos 4 y además tiene que estar en la
misma línea horizontal que c
así que vamos a estar en este punto y
debe tener la misma coordenada en verdad
así que este es 3
este es nuestro punto de no tenemos que
menos 4 está en equis y ya está
y es igual a 3 así que está en el
segundo cuadrante y acabamos